Let's update the view
will appear function so
that the stop recording button is
disabled right from the start.
Take out the print line and
now the following to view will appear.
Let's make the stop recording
button disabled by default.
Now we need to wait to enable
the stop recording button and
at the same time disable
the record button.
There are two functions you wrote
earlier that can help us here,
in the record audio function,
we can add the following two lines.
One line to enable the stop
recording button and
the second line to disable
the record button.
Finally in the stop recording function,
we can add the following three lines.
We can set the record button back to
enable, we can disable the recording
button, and we can reset
the text on the recording label.
Let's test it.
We can run that by clicking
the run button up here or
pressing command r on your keyboard.
We can see right away that the stop
recording button has been disabled
when the view loads.
If you click record we can
see the label has changed and
now the stop recording buttons enabled.
At the same time the recording button
is disabled because we're
actually recording.
If we hit stop this button
is unable to get in and
the label has changed
back to Tap to Record.